continuing in this vein of wonder we
have rubber who done this is the
gentleman who revealed the defecating
duck to be a fake so he did many things
and not only was he an incredible clock
maker and magician and also invented the
mystery clock he actually was hired by
the French government to put down a
rebellion
so his magic was so good they hired him
to go out and pretend to be a sorcerer
and he basically saved France so not
many clock makers can put that on their
CV what's most interesting is the fact
that robert-houdin was the son of a
watchmaker and had planned to be a
watchmaker but actually went to law
school and while he went to a book shop
to collect a two-volume set on law he
was mistakenly given a two-volume set on
magic and the world was never the same
he ended up moving into Paris and
marrying the daughter of a prominent
clock maker and his time there really
rebase achill ii totally redid magic
he's considered the father of modern
magic and was the first magician to
incorporate mechanical devices and
clocks using electricity into his shows
which was definitely a result of his
work as a clock maker so not only did
who then inspire a lot of firms to
actually go on and develop other mystery
clocks but he also inspired the very
famous Russian goldsmith Peter Carl
Faberge
so Faberge was the goldsmith to the Czar
Nicholas ii and took much of his
inspiration from master works of the
past so this is his version of the
Houdon orange tree this is known as the
bay tree egg this is from 1911 so
instead of having the handkerchief that
carries this piece with the butterflies
it actually has a singing bird in the
center which is also a homage to jack
aid rose who invented the singing bird
here is none other than his tiny silver
swan otamatone this actually came in
another one of his beautiful eggs
he actually had 52 of these eggs that
were created by Faberge for the Czar
Nicholas ii he had a standing order of
two of these every year so there was one
for his mother and one for his wife this
beautiful egg has matte lilac enamel
it has the Swan that sits in a bed of
aquamarine with all these beautiful
little flowers what's probably most
surprising thing about this mechanical
swan is the fact that it is actually
made of gold and then played it in
silver how's that for an Easter present
and this is from the Year 1906 when
Peter Carl took over his father's firm
there was definitely this move from
producing jewelry to producing kind of
artists jeweler type objects so this
particular one was the peacock egg don't
know if I mentioned this but his mother
got all of the mechanical ones so this
was this beautiful peacock that
certainly had to have been influenced by
another older artwork since the fabergé
firm was actually also the keepers of
the objects inside the Hermitage they
looked after and repaired many of the
objects within the collection there this
allowed Faberge to go and study all of
these older pieces and build replicas
and different pieces that would pay
homage to these master works of the past
[Music]
you